asap rocky and rihanna were all smiles
as they filmed together in new york city
over the weekend
now a source tells e.t the two are madly
in love i couldn't tell you how happy i
am
the couple were all loved up in the
bronx
enjoying a multi-day shoot for the 32
year old rapper's new music video
on saturday the two were spotted walking
down the street on set together
that's the 33 year old singer rocking a
yellow printed
scarf corset top brown pants heels
and a heavy fleece-lined overcoat and
that's
asap in head to toe black with a gold
belt
and trucker hat i love it the source
added that the power couple packed on
the pda
hugging holding hands and snuggling up
to one another
quote between takes they were very
[Music]
lovey-dovey
on sunday the couple continued the shoot
on a fire escape
rihanna in a pink neon fur coat and lime
green heels
asap in a matching lime green fur hat
with a tank top
jeans and boots and e.t source says fans
are going to
love this new music video and this song
adding it's going to be like getting a
glimpse into their relationship
but this isn't the first time rihanna
has starred in one of asap's music
videos
back in 2013 she played his girlfriend
in his fashion killa video
she may never wear it but she save it so
our babies will be flyer than their
parents
the couple has also collaborated on
music in the past
asap was featured on the 2011 remix for
her song
cockiness
of course rumors of romance between the
two first sparked
last july when riri featured rocky in
her fenty skin campaign
to me in in the industry he's one of the
guys that like
everybody loves his skin i mean i've
always wanted to know like how the heck
do you have better skin like half these
girls i mean like what what do you do
at the time the umbrella singer opened
up to e.t about why she chose him for
her ads
i wanted men to be represented because
this
skincare line is gender neutral i needed
that male representation
in the campaign and so rocky and nan's
nazax
we wanted that male representation so
men knew that it was okay
so it's no surprise the two want to work
together now that they're in a
relationship
e.t source says quote they are so madly
in love
they barely leave each other's side asap
is so grateful for rihanna she's his
biggest cheerleader and he doesn't take
her for granted
just last week a source told et that
rihanna accompanied him to the studio to
support him as he recorded new material
and when et recently spoke to the rapper
about his documentary stockholm syndrome
he opened up about having his superstar
girlfriend support
it's amazing and i'm honestly truly
blessed real you know